this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer Barcelona is a
city characterized by regimental city
blocks and white linear streets a
departure from the narrow winding
streets of most European cities yet
nestled in these rigid streets are some
of the most unique and beautiful
buildings ever created each rooted in
nature through structural forms and
designs these beautiful structures stand
out among their neighbors and are the
work of one of the world's greatest
architects Antony Gaudi his buildings
were not just inspired by nature they
were a celebration of nature a
celebration of life and a celebration of
the god Gaudi devoted his life to casa
milà casa Valeo and perhaps most
famously the yet to be finished Sagrada
família all are within a short walk of
each other and each is defined by their
complex curves that defied all
conventional architectural rules these
buildings were born from the mind of
Antony Gowdy born in 1852 to a family of
craftsmen Antony Gowdy found much of his
inspiration and meaning in architecture
by following the patterns of nature
using the beauty that he saw as a gift
from God as the ultimate blueprint to
the world Gaudi himself once said
originality consists of going back to
the origins and that he did these
complex intertwining parabolic forms
created in a time before computers
existed her so complex that his magnum
opus the Sagrada família a building
which began construction over a hundred
and thirty-five years ago is still under
construction today we're going to learn
its story and why it has taken
generations to complete Sagrada família
began construction in 1882 under the
guidance of architect Francisco de Paula
Valliere who resigned a year later
allowing Gaudi to take over at the age
of 30 even at this young age Gaudi saw
his opportunity and set out to make the
project his master
transforming the project and
incorporating his signature style
combining gothic and Aris nouvelle
architecture to create something
completely new
sandra de familia looks like the work of
evolution rather than design like a
joint elaborate termite mount whose
blueprint was carved from the laws of
nature Gaudi was not just a master
architect designing buildings and
creative and innovative ways is the
challenge of an artist he was a master
engineer he understood how these shapes
impacted the structural integrity of the
building and allowed physics and nature
to dictate his designs rather than fight
against the laws of nature he worked
with them he bridged art and science
like no man before him he understood
that nature is defined by the laws of
mathematics and to him this was the
ultimate celebration of God columns
mimicking trees and skeletons arches
smearing rib cages seashell inspired
spiral stairways spires emulating
crystals and ceilings that rival forest
canopies for natural beauty their
designs are all rooted in natural
phenomenon but for a human mind to
recreate them in stone took a man with
true genius so how on earth that Antoni
gaudí
designed something so complex in an era
when computational analysis did not
exist
evolution has happened upon these
complicated structures true trial and
error natural arches are the work of
chance the weeks simply fall before we
can witness them while plants developed
cells capable of sensing the direction
of gravity to influence their growth
patterns and bone cells are stimulated
to grow and multiply when placed under
stress nature is the ultimate form of
intelligent design and Gaudi pursued a
simple concept to guide his replication
of these designs the challenge that
Gaudi faced was one of material
strengths his primary building material
being manju 'ok stone a type of
sandstone unlike all stone it is
strongest in compression
place a rock in compression and I can
withstand enormous pressure but place it
in tension and tiny imperfections in the
rock allow cracks to grow and soon the
entire stone will fracture along those
cracks the challenge with constructing
structures using stone is primarily one
of keeping the stone in compression at
all times this has been a well-known
building technique for thousands of
years but it was the Romans who truly
saw and utilized its potential
unlike ancient Greek structures
characterized by vertical posts and
horizontal lintel constructions Roman
buildings are defined by arches and
domes
they raised massive structures like
their famous aqueducts and the Pantheon
dome structures that still stand today a
testament to their sturdiness the arches
strength is derived from how it
transfers waste to the ground let's
compare a post and lintel structure and
an arch spanning an equal distance as
long as the posts remain vertical they
will remain entirely in compression the
downwards force of gravity squeezing the
stones against the unmoving ground
however the horizontal beam the lintel
will experience both compression and
tension as it sags from its own weight
the upper surface will bend inwards
causing compression while the lower
surface will experience tension as it is
stretched this severely limits its
structural strength an arch in
comparison allows the force to be
distributed neatly across the arch there
are no hard corners to allow bending
stresses to develop the reaction force
from the ground can travel smoothly up
the same path as the force of gravity
takes downwards allowing the stones to
remain in compression and thus allowing
the urge to carry more weight this
imaginary path is called the line of
thrust and modeling it was gaudi's
specialty designing with these concepts
in mind is relatively simple with a 2d
structure like an aqueduct but expanding
it out to form something as complex as
an gratifi Miglia is a whole other
ballgame even the simple columns of the
basilica's interior splash and diverge
like growing trees the flying buttresses
of the
passion facade sweep outwards a defy
belief that they could possibly remain
standing when they are constructed from
nothing more than sandstone so how did
Gaudi do it simple
he used strengths when you hang a
flexible material like a rope over a gap
it has no rigidity to allow us to remain
in any position other than the one that
allows it to remain in pure tension hang
a rope from a single point and it will
hang directly downwards the entire
length of the string in tension hang it
between two points and it will sag
downwards until once again the entire
string is in tension add more waste and
it will sag with a deeper parabolic arch
to allow us to remain in tension you can
see a pattern developing here we can use
strings to map out these lines of thrust
boss we want our stones to be in
compression not tension how can we apply
this to stones simple take a photo and
turn it upside down Gaudi started by
drawing the footprint of the church on a
piece of wood at a 1 to 10 scale next he
attached anchor points for the strings
in locations where he wanted support
columns to exist from there he gradually
started adding strings and weights the
weights were scaled to represent the
actual weight the columns would need to
support at about 110 thousand of the
actual weight this weight was scaled to
represent the difference in stiffness
between the string and the rock that it
represented he tinkered with a string
model for a decade before he was content
with its final form he used this model
to inform his design work in this
reconstructed model underneath the
Sangre de Familia you can see the shape
of the building beginning to emerge this
was the skeleton upon which he would
care of his masterpiece Gaudi devoted
the rest of his life to carving this
model designing the intricate facades
each depicting stories from the Bible
adding detail that few would see and ask
the project ran on Gaudi were true from
life rejecting any additional projects
in 1914 he made his home inside the
Sagrada família workshop his obsession
with his final masterpiece took over his
life
he neglected his personal appearance and
became a disheveled recluse his days
were devoted to brain and overseen the
design and construction of the Sagrada
família and on June 7th 1926 disaster
struck at the age of 73 Gaudi was struck
by a tram on his daily walk to
confession and was left to die in the
streets passerbys did not recognize the
ragged man as the famous and beloved
architect hours later Gaudi was taken to
the hospital but received only basic
care when he was finally recognized it
was too late no more could be done to
save his life and he died two days later
on June 10th 1926 the funeral the
followed shut down Barcelona streets the
residents of Barcelona showed up on mass
merging his coffin to its final resting
place in the crypt of the Sagrada
família the project was less than a
quarter complete at the time of his
death with the mastermind behind the
complex project God completing it would
become a Herculean task made even more
difficult by the outbreak of the Spanish
Civil War
in 1936 an already difficult task just
became the world's most difficult puzzle
as anarchists destroyed the only
existing models of gaudí's designs
[Music]
here the building could have been
abandoned or its vision changed as Spain
shook off the cobwebs of post-war
poverty in the 1950s a new generation of
engineers and craftsmen devoted their
skills to completing gaudi's vision
employing tools and materials that Gaudi
never had access to attempts to piece
together the shattered models back
together were difficult as pieces were
either too damaged or missing completely
but the designers that took up gaudi's
vision worked with what they had this is
now their story this is where this story
really begins to captivate me this
building has taken so long to complete
that it has spawned not just generations
of Engineers but generations of
Technology the passage of time has led
to some increases in production rates
but has also caused its fair share of
delays sandstone comes in a wide variety
of colors due to differences in
impurities these can range from blues
and grays right through to pink and red
when construction began on Sagrada
família this sandstone was in plentiful
supply from the mantua quarry it's this
stone that gives the Sangre de familia
its distinctive tan color while also
having a high quartz content making it
more durable than most sedimentary rocks
but as the decades passed the stone
began to become more scarce in 1954 when
work began on the passion facade the
limited stock of the stone quickly
became apparent
soon the sculptors hands became idle as
the stones availability was limited to
whatever was left over in stocks or what
could be scavenged from other buildings
in Catalonia 1000 meters cubed of the
stone was made available when the old
olympic stadium was remodeled to
increase spectator capacity when stone
was not available they resorted to
bricks which can be seen in many of the
cathedrals towers but recycled stone was
always preferred when possible as the
project drew on these sources began to
run dry creating a bottleneck in their
supply chain that prevented work from
continuing the projects managers were
forced to start looking for alternative
supplies from around the world over the
past few decades of construction the
Cathedral has incorporated various
variants of sandstone and granite from
around the world doing their best to
match their color and physical
properties to the original manju extol
stone from Galatia Cantabria Scotland
England and France have all contributed
to help finish the Sagrada família while
other stones have been sourced to meet
more specific aesthetic requirements the
passage of time has come with plenty of
setbacks but in recent years technology
has provided many blessings obvious
improvements like modern cranes are
noticeable yet probably underappreciated
by the general public
3d modeling software is have slowly
caught up with gaudi's genius early
civil engineering software was too
simple to recreate his designs both
architects working on the project
discovered that aeronautical engineering
design software could model the complex
curves Gaudi envisioned and the project
actually resulted in a merging of these
software's to improve civil engineering
modeling techniques cash flow has
increased drastically over the years to
four decades the only money the Sagrada
família received was through donations
to the church in the early days of
construction these donations came in
dribs and drabs
but today the church has no shortage of
funding being one of the most popular
tourist sites in the world since it
opened its doors to the public Sangre de
Familia has been raising a consistent
and reliable cash flow from the millions
of tourists to pay to visit it every
year this helps pay for the materials
and workers needed to complete us but
those workers are not always easy to
come by the art of sculpting has slowly
withered away over the past century and
skilled craftsmen are difficult to come
by here technology has come in to lend a
helping hand sculptors still play an
important role in the process completing
delicate tasks like surface texturing
but today most of the heavy-duty coding
is now done by CNC machines which can
cut the stone exactly to requirements
and ensure perfect fits between the
pieces for the internal steel supports
because today the workers are not
assembling the tower is stone by stone
like in gaudi's time there are using
tension steel bars
running through the center of the stones
to compress the stones together and form
a larger panel allowing pieces to be
partially assembled before being lifted
to the tower and assembled like a giant
stone Lego set this has drastically
decreased construction time with all of
these advances the project is now
expected to finish far sooner than
originally expected by 2026 on the 100th
anniversary of gaudí's death the
building has undoubtedly diverged from
gaudi's original designs the sculptures
of the passion facade are nothing like
the sculptures of the nativity facade
built during gaudi's lifetime colors of
stone are often places the difference in
weathering between the nativity facade
and the newer parts is particularly
noticeable the architects that took up
the mantle of gaudí's masterpiece could
never have finished it exactly to his
vision after his plans were destroyed
but I have no doubt in my mind that
gaudi would be proud to see his creation
finally come to a close
entering the basilica you are met with
floods of color from the stained-glass
windows each depicting stories from the
Bible while filling the interior with
colors reminiscent of rainbows sunsets
and light piercing through a green
forest canopy I am by no means a
religious man but there is something
inherently spiritual about this building
and I think any person who shares that
same aw of our mysterious existence on
this planet will feel the same for me
that is the root of all religions and to
me this building is the ultimate
celebration of spirituality through its
celebration of nature in the end I
believe I express a great deal of my all
with this world through learning how it
works I don't believe in the idea that
learning science runes are innate Wonder
and awe in the mysteries of the world
it's the exact opposite the more I learn
about how the universe works the more
amazed I am that we somehow exist
witness at all
so satisfy the feeling of wonder and
dive into the world of science and
there's no better place to start than
brain with plenty of courses and things
like geometry and maths so you can learn
more about the
complex parabolic curves the gaudi used
or you could take the classical
mechanics course which will run you
through the science of statics essential
knowledge for any civil engineer
brilliant are continually releasing new
courses to like their new course on
search engines where you'll explore the
core ideas behind algorithms and data
structures that make search engines work
all of brilliants courses have
storytelling code writing interactive
challenges and problems to solve so you
can learn by doing no matter which
course you choose brilliant will guide
you from your current knowledge base to
where you want to be this by Biss
leaving you two fascinating revelations
about our universe if i have inspired
you and you want to educate yourself
then go to brain Torg ford slash real
engineering and sign up for free and the
first 500 people that go to that link
will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so you can get full access
to all their courses as well as their
entire daily challenges archive as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below